you're here and you'll see in what's
happening in Iran and you are speaking
up
does it feel helpless to you
or you think you can help affect change
it is very difficult and of course
there are many of us who live outside
Iranian Exile and we would have loved to
be able to go back to Iran at such
circumstances but most of us can't
um but the story of what is happening in
Iran at the moment
resonates with my story in many
different levels but also in a way that
I was abducted at the airport I was in
Communicator for about a month nobody
knew where I was and this is exactly
what is happening to many women who are
protesting in the streets at the moment
they often get arrested put in an
unknown Place nobody knows where they
are
and I think
um
what happened to masamini showed the
brutality of the police force in Iran in
a way
but but then if we step back I just want
to mention that um
uh the issue of hijab in Iran is not a
religious matter
it is a political matter that leads
directly to the sovereignty of the
Iranian regime so Iranian governments
has been systematically repressing
Iranian women and this whole system of
repression is the main tool they have
you were
put into solitary confinement for many
many weeks
and you talked about being broken
emotional how they break the regime
break people emotionally can you explain
a bit more if you're comfortable about
what you mean by that what that
experience is I was in solitary Carolina
for nine months
which compared to some other people is
actually nothing so
when I was in Evan when I was in the
general award you know we had anilofar
near far bayani who was one of the
conservationists she was one of the
eight people
who were arrested in 2018
under charges of spying for the Iranian
regime
and um she had been to uh she had been
in solitary for 23 months
throughout which she had gone through
1200 hours of interrogation and if you
think about any confession coming out of
that is there any value on that like if
you break people to the point
that they are
emotionally tortured anything coming out
of that is not valuable real it's not
real I guess
though for you
there's been dozens there's been dozens
of people reportedly murdered there's
been
hundreds of arrests
so every single one of those to use in
your mind think what could be happening
to that person that's quite that must be
quite a burden actually to carry because
it must bring a lot back it does but
also
my story was a Happy Ending Story
I came out of it alive and what really
makes me upset is in some of the cases
that we see on a daily basis we have got
nikoshak Army who was 16 and she was a
resident she was killed
um and her family found her body I mean
they they brought their body back to the
family about 10 days after she was
disappeared so in many of the cases they
do not actually come back alive
and I think the world cannot turn a
blind eye this is just not acceptable
with this trust I mean she is now the
Prime Minister you know her personally I
mean she helped
peculiar release what's happening Iran
now is that something you feel you could
or should raise with her well when we
met when I came back
we talked about
um
um this shouldn't have happened
um six years after my arrest and it
should have happened earlier and then
she promised that she will be in touch
with the Canadian counterparts in terms
of uh putting an end to the Iranian
hostage taking diplomacy so she did make
that promise so what I was expecting
was listruss to condemn what is
happening in Iran but I think what I
what we saw was a statement from the
Ministry of Foreign Affairs and not
listro not the prime minister
so you want her to actually be more
robust in this and given what she has
gone through and she knows what is
happening in Iran she has just secured
the release of me and Anusha so she is
very much aware of you know what is
happening in the country
condemning uh what is happening in the
country in Iran and he's showing a
statement is not enough
but it's a good gesture
but that is not enough in a way because
um countries have got their own agenda
so they do businesses with Iran they
have got diplomatic relationships with
Iran so they probably put that a
priority so if they want to issue an a
statement in terms of condemning what is
happening in Iran they would take into
account what that how that would impact
their own relationship